something you said triggered a question
I have further down but I'll bump it up
and that was you were talking about the
music video
love of the film that you made while you
were in law school and then I saw a
video that you did where you say when a
book turns into a film that a game and
then a comic book
that's not transmedia it's multimedia so
can we talk about how many people think
that that is transmedia and and dispel
some of the myths yeah so the you know
the especially in the 80s we had this
boom of the multimedia franchise and
multimedia is is the same story that's
adapted across multiple mediums you know
the the book becomes the movie that
movie becomes the the graphic novel that
graphic novel becomes the video game
it's basically the same story and the
same plot over and over and over again
just Express Express through multiple
mediums transmedia is sort of this
second cousin of that and where instead
of having the Twilight books become the
Twilight movie that becomes a Twilight
videogame that becomes the Twilight
graphic novel now we have the books that
then set up the movie that then lead
into the graphic novel that then
culminates in the videogame all the
different touch points tell a different
completely different story but in a way
though where all the stories work
together to tell one big story and
that's that's a different process but it
was it was birthed out of the the
necessity of of the marketplace and now
that you know it you have grown up in
the 80s and the 90s the multimedia
franchise was fine because there what
else are you going to do we didn't have
the 8,000 different entertainment
options that we have today it was real
imited and so you were the consumers and
audiences were okay with just
experiencing the same story over and
over and over again because there were
very limited amounts of options today we
now have you know 8,000 television
channels we have cable satellite network
Netflix Hulu Amazon we have millions of
YouTube videos we have access to every
TV show ever made every movie ever
every book ever written we have millions
of mobile games that are available just
in our pocket anytime we want and so now
when we can entertain ourselves with
anything that we want the marketplace
has been going for new stuff rather than
repurpose content so if you give a
consumer the option of a video game
where you already know the story and a
video game that you don't know the story
now they're opting for the new story
they're opting for the new book they're
opting for the new movie because they
just don't want to repurpose the same
thing over and over and over again so
when the audience is now demand new new
new you you have to figure out how to
continually give them new story rather
than repurpose story which then has
created this really interesting
opportunity in the marketplace but at
the same time obstacle in the
marketplace because now we have to
figure out how to continually tell new
stories because the multimedia franchise
just isn't performing the way it used to
perform and so so just like any good
good capitalistic system the market is
the one that that pushes toward change
and that's what we've seen over the past
ten years
you